What do you say to those of you that
don't pursue their dreams are locked
into their careers because they are too
afraid to take risks and pursue
something meaningful?
Well,
the first thing I would say is,
well,
you shouldn't be afraid of taking risks
and pursuing something meaningful,
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are.
If it's making you miserable,
it's like the first thing you want to do
is dispense with the idea that you get
to have any,
any permanent security outside of your
ability to contend and adapt.
It's the same issue with children.
It's like you're paying a price by
sitting there being miserable.
You might say,
well,
the devil I know is better than the one
I don't.
It's like,
don't be so sure of that.
The clock is ticking and if you're
miserable in your job now and you change
nothing in five years,
you'll be much more miserable and you'll
be a lot older,
but there's in the luxury to pursue what
is meaningful.
Our viewers have more.
They have children,
they have payments on loans.
It's a luxury to pursue because we lack
the resources.
Well,
I don't think.
I don't remember.
Now.
I'm not talking about what makes you
happy.
It's a luxury to pursue what makes you
It's a moral obligation to pursue what
you find meaningful and that doesn't
mean it's easy.
It might require sacrifice.
If you need to change your job to,
let's say you have a family and children
and a mortgage,
you have responsibilities.
You've already picked up those
responsibilities.
You don't just get to walk away Scott
free.
Say,
well,
I don't like my job.
I quit.
That's no strategy,
but what you might have to do is you
think,
well,
this job is killing my soul.
All right,
so what do I have to do about that?
Well,
I have to look for another job while no
one wants to hire me.
It's like,
okay,
maybe you need to educate yourself more.
Maybe you need to update your
curriculum,
veto your resume.
Maybe you need to overcome your fear of
being interviewed.
Maybe you need to sharpen your social
skills like you.
You have to think about these things
strategically.
If you're going to switch careers,
you have to do it like an intelligent,
responsible person that might take you a
couple of years of effort to do
properly.
When you say pursue something
meaningful,
is it important to have a vocation?
I think it's more important to to have a
an ethos and ethic,
so I have a program,
for example,
called the future authoring program,
which is a writing program that enables
people to develop a vision for their
life and then to develop a strategy and
so it's based on the idea.
Imagine that and it's an extension of
the ideas in the book or at least
something along the same lines.
The first thing that you want to do is
figure out.
Imagine you were taking care of yourself
like you were someone you cared for,
which is rule number two,
by the way,
essentially.
Then you should figure out,
well,
if you could have what you needed and
wanted,
what would it be?
What sort of friends would you have?
What would your family relationships
look like?
How would you conduct yourself with your
children?
How would you educate?
You need to think through how it is that
your life could be properly arranged if
you had that ability and then you can
name it that.
And the funny thing is is that if you do
positive goal of that sort and work
towards it,
you will move towards it.
The goal will change because you'll
learn things along the way.
But I mean I've,
I've dealt with hundreds of people in my
clinical and consulting practice and we
set a goal,
we develop a vision and work towards it
and it,
it,
things inevitably get better for people.
So it's not a luxury,
it's,
it's difficult.
It's a moral responsibility and it isn't
happiness.
It's,
it's not.
The pursuit isn't for happiness.
It's a moral responsibility to push you.
What has meaning?
Absolutely.
So when you know,
if you watch yourself,
you say,
well,
I had a particularly good day at work
and what does that mean?
Well,
it means that you lost your sense of
time,
right?
Because when you're having a good day at
work,
it's like first it's one minute to three
and then it's
45 seconds to three and then it's 30
seconds.
That's what school was like for me.
It was like
trick.
So funny.
You know,
I went to,
I went to my daughter's school,
I used to get in trouble for talking all
the time,
surprise,
surprise when I was a kid and uh,
and I was bored stiff in school and,
and so I would misbehave upon occasion
out of pure boredom.
And about 21 years ago I went to my
daughter's school to sit for a class.
It was about an hour long.
And uh,
I was sitting there and the teacher had
all the kids on the floor and was having
some of the kids read to the others.
And some of the kids who were reading
couldn't read at all.
And I had exactly the same experience.
I was sitting there.
It was like being,
it's like being seven years old,
ugly.
And I could see the clock going,
tick,
tick.
And I thought,
you know,
if I was in this classroom for three
days,
I would misbehave,
fit 40 years old,
I would misbehave exactly like I did
when I was when I was six.
Well,
that's no place to be right,
because that's.
You don't want to be in a place that
stultifying you don't want to be in a
place where there's no challenge.
You might even quit your job if there's
no challenge.
Say,
well that's a good job.
It gives you security and you think,
God,
I can't stand this.
It's eating away at my soul.
It's all security and no challenge.
So why do you want to challenge?
Because that's what you're built for.
That's what you're built for your built
to take on a maximal load,
right?
Because that's what strengthens you and
you need to be strong because life is
extraordinarily difficult and because
the evil king is always whittling away
at the structure of the state and you
have to be awake and sharp to stop that
from happening so that you don't become
corrupt and so that your family doesn't
become corrupt and so that your state
doesn't have to be come become corrupt.
You have to have your eyes open and your
wits sharp and your words at the ready
and you have to be educated and you have
to know about your history and you know
how have to know how to think and you
have to know how to read and you have to
know how to speak and you have to know
how to aim and you have to be willing to
hoist the troubles of the world up on
your shoulders.
And what's so interesting about that?
So remarkable.
And,
and this is something that's really
manifested itself to me as I've been
doing these public lectures.
I've been talking about responsibility
to people,
which doesn't seem to happen very often
anymore.
And the audiences are dead quiet,
and I lay out this idea that life is
tragedy tainted by malevolence,
and everyone says,
yeah,
well we already always suspected that no
one has ever said it quite so bluntly,
and it's quite a relief to hear that I'm
not the only person who has those
suspicions.
And then the second part of that is the
better part,
and it's the optimistic part,
which is despite the fact that life is a
tragedy tainted by malevolence at every
level of existence,
there's something about the human spirit
that can thrive under precisely those
conditions if we allow that to occur.
Because as difficult as life is and as
horrible as we are,
our capacity to deal with that
catastrophe and to transcend that
malevolent spirit is more powerful than
the than that reality itself.
And that's the fundamental issue.
I think that's the fundamental issue of
the Judaeo Christian ethic with its
emphasis on the divinity of the
individual.
As catastrophic as life is and his
malevolent as people can be.
And that's malevolent beyond belief.
Fundamentally,
a person has in spirit the nobility to
set that right and to defeat evil and
that and that more than that and that
the antidote to the catastrophe of life
and the suffering of life and the
tragedy of life that can drive you down
and destroy you,
is to take on exactly that
responsibility and to say,
well,
there's plenty of work to be done and
isn't that terrible and there isn't
anything so bad that we can't make it
worse and certainly try very hard to do
so,
but I have it within me to decide that
I'm going to stand up against that.
I'm going to strive to make the world a
better place.
I'm going to strive to constrain the
malevolence that's in my own heart and
to set my family's straight and to work
to work despite my tragic lot for the
betterment of anything,
of everything that's in front of me.
And the consequence of that.
The immediate consequence of that is
that when you make the decision to take
on all of that voluntarily,
which is to stand up straight,
by the way,
with your shoulders back to take on
that,
all that on voluntarily.
As soon as you make that decision,
then all the catastrophe justifies
itself in the nobility of your striving
and that's what it means to be an
individual.
Thank you.
When I was 25 or so,
I probably weighed about 138 pounds.
I smoked like a pack cigarettes day.
I drank tremendous amount of alcohol.
I was from northern Alberta,
this rough little town up in northern
Alberta called fairview and you know,
there were long winters there and my
friends were heavy drinkers and most of
them dropped out of school by the time
they were 15 or 16 and went off to work
on the oil rigs.
And you know,
it was a rough town and we drank a lot
and I started when I was 14 and you
know,
um,
and so I was,
I had a lot of bad habits,
let's say,
and things that were.
And I wasn't in great shape physically
and I was also still intellectually
obsessed by as I am now.
And uh,
so that would've been,
that would've been an 85,
but when I,
but I decided around that about 85,
84,
something like that,
maybe a little earlier than I was really
going to try to get my act together.
And,
uh,
so I started doing that.
I,
you know,
first of all,
I quit smoking.
Oh,
that took a long time because I
eventually had to quit drinking too in
order to quit smoking.
And I started working out,
started playing sports,
which I'd never done.
I was a small kid.
I been skipped a grade and I was a
small,
small for my age.
So sports were never,
especially team sports were never really
a domain of expertise for me.
Although I skied and went shopping with
my dad,
went cross country skiing and camping
and all that.
So,
but,
uh,
when I went to graduate school,
I started swimming the first,
the first,
uh,
physical exercise routine.
I did.
I enrolled in a swim suicides course,
I think it was called.
It was me and this like really
overweight kid and like these 60 year
old women and men naked out exercise me
like mad.
It was really embarrassing me in the
overweight kid,
you know,
we'd be just panting ourselves three
quarters to death at the end of the
bloody workout in these 60 year old
women who weren't great shape or like,
you know,
chatting way as if nothing was going on
at all in the pool.
So that was quite embarrassing as was
going to the weight room,
you know,
because when I started I could barely
bench press 75 pounds and people used to
keep coming over and helping me,
which was lasting I bloody well wanted
but certainly needed.
And I got to the point where I could
bench press 225 pounds.
I think that was the best I did.
And I gained about 30 pounds of muscle
in a year and a half.
So that was good thing.
So like I was kind of a wild man and you
know,
I'm a little bit manic in my,
in my temperament.
And so,
you know,
I was,
I was kind of going every direction at
the same time,
so,
and uh,
you know,
I don't regret that I had a fine time
when I was a kid and I needed really to
get disciplined and I had to do it
because I was working on these hard
problems that,
you know,
that I've been discussing with all of
you and I've been working on them really
obsessively since I was probably about
18,
maybe even earlier than that.
And got to the point around 25 when I
was in graduate school trying to get my
phd,
doing all my research.
Like I published 15 papers by the time I
graduated with my phd,
which was by I think by a fairly large
measure,
the most papers that any graduate
student at that time had ever published
at mcgill.
I think that's right.
Might have been twice as many or maybe
twice as many,
maybe even three times as many.
And at the same time I wrote maps of
meaning,
which was terrible,
terrible,
terribly difficult thing to do because I
was writing about three hours a day
doing that.
And I couldn't do all that and continue
with my misbehavior,
you know,
my sort of my what,
what would you say?
My,
my,
my hedonistic,
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that.
I just couldn't keep it up and also work
seriously on the issues that were at
hand.
So,
you know,
I had to stop.
That's a sacrifice I had to stop messing
about,
straighten myself out.
And I,
I got married while my,
the woman who is my wife Tammy,
who I've known since she was eight years
old,
she lived across the street from me in
this little town called fairview.
And I was in love with her like first
time I saw her,
which is quite bloody thing.
So that's worked out pretty well for me.
But she came to live with me about the
same time and you know,
we decided jointly to get our act
together and we swore that we tell each
other the truth,
which I think she's actually done better
than me.
Like I don't think,
I don't think she's lied to me ever in
our entire marriage,
which is unbelievable,
you know?
And it's been so useful because I can
really tell her things that we can
really talk.
So I tell you,
if you want to have a good relationship,
man,
you embedded in the truth.
Because if you don't embed it in the
truth,
you don't have a relationship.
It's,
it's just lies.
It's a tissue of lies.
And it will,
it will dissolve in the chaos as soon as
the crisis comes along.
So the truth is a terrible thing,
but not,
not compared to falsehood.
So.
Alright,
so let's look at the live chat here.
You hear the Galitary Ian Clarion call
everywhere.
Everything should be equal.
Everything should be equally
distributed.
We should strive for equity.
It's like wrong,
especially if you're a conservative,
wrong.
What we want are just hierarchies of
competence.
Not everyone's a neurosurgeon.
You know,
if your father has a brain tumor,
you probably want a hierarchy of
competence for neurosurgeons.
So you can pick the one that's the best
so that he might not die.
That's what a hierarchy of competence is
for,
for the postmodernist.
There's no hierarchy that isn't based on
power.
Well,
because they think the world runs on
power and that's why they're willing to
use power to get what they want because
it's the only thing they believe it,
but a valid hierarchy of competence.
It's God.
We need those things,
man.
We need the best plumbers.
We need the best contractors.
We need best.
We knew we need the best carpenters.
We need the best lecturers.
There has to be a hierarchy of quality,
not only so that we know who the best
are and to reward them properly,
but so that we can reward them so they
keep being the best.
It's like you know if,
if you have a great educator,
if you have a great leader,
if you,
if you have a great thinker,
you want to reward them so they keep
thinking and keep educating so they can
tell you something.
It's not a reward for their intrinsic
being.
It's a calculated move on your part to
suck everything out of them.
That's valuable as fast as you can.
That's what a hierarchy of competence is
for and the idea that hierarchies of
competence don't exist is it's so
cynical.
It's such a pathologically cynical idea
and it's actually quite patently untrue
because here's an interesting tidbit
from the psychological literature.
Let's say you want to determine what the
best predictors are for lifetime success
in a Western society.
Well,
what would you hope for?
How about intelligence?
There would be a good one.
Let's hope the smart people occupied
more positions of complexity,
right?
Because they're smarter.
Would you want it any other way?
Okay,
and then so and that's great.
The number one predictor of
accomplishment in western societies is
intelligence,
so that means the system works.
What's the number to predictor
conscientiousness?
Well,
what's that?
It's a trademark or for hard work.
So who called,
who gets a head smart?
People who work hard.
Now that doesn't account for every bit
of the difference between people in
terms of their hierarchical structure
because hierarchies aren't perfect.
They're corrupt.
People get to the top sometimes because
there's psychopathic,
although believe me,
a hell of a lot less than you think
because a psychopath has to keep moving
from place to place because once he
reveals himself as deceitful,
untrustworthy,
he has to go find new soccer's to
fleece.
So the idea that you know,
there's no distinction between a CEO and
a psychopath.
It's like that's only made by someone
who knows nothing about psychopaths
being knows nothing about ceos and c has
something fundamental against the entire
capitalist structure because it's simply
not true.
Corrupt,
sometimes greedy,
sometimes short sighted,
sometimes running companies that are
doing their best to auger themselves
into the ground and so,
you know,
it's bad people running a dying
organization,
but generally speaking,
it's not the case.
Our hierarchies of competence are
reasonably functional and not only are
they functional,
they're valuable.
We need to know who the competent people
are and we need to reward them.
And even more importantly,
we need to tell young people,
hey,
there's some hierarchies of competence
out there,
like a thousand of them.
Go be a plumber man,
but be a good one.
You know,
being honest,
one B,
I had a plumber once,
you know,
it was the night,
it was the night before we were putting
drywall in our house.
We were redoing a house and he had put
in all the plastic piping,
you know,
and I was going to test the joints,
the they're supposed to be glued
together with his pipe glue.
And I said,
I told them I had to test the joints and
he said,
well you don't have to test my joints.
They never leak.
Can I thought,
yeah,
that's okay.
How about if I test them?
So I went up on the third floor and
filled the pipes with water,
capping them in the basement like you're
supposed to.
Like half an hour later I had two inches
of water in the basement.
There were 30 leaking joints and that
was the night before the drywallers were
supposed to show up so well.
So he wasn't particularly competent.
That's the point of that story.
But even more so he had put a bunch of
the plastic pipe outside where the
drywall would be.
So it would have been sticking through
the wall.
So I spent a frenetic night,
you know,
sawing through plastic pipe and re
gluing joints so that my well so that
the drywall is could come in.
What's the point if you're going to be a
plumber,
man,
be a good plumber because otherwise all
you do is go out there and cause
trouble.
We don't need people to cause more
We need people to solve problems,
you know,
and so you can be a tradesman and you
can be,
can make a lot of money as a
tradesperson.
That's a bloody reliable,
honorable,
a forthright,
productive way of making a living.
And there is a hell of a lot of
difference between a working man who
knows what he's doing and one who
doesn't,
both in terms of skill and ethics,
right?
And you work with someone who knows what
they're doing,
it's a bloody pleasure.
They tell you what they're gonna do.
They tell you how much it will cost.
They go and do it.
It works,
and you pay them perfect.
Everyone's happy.
And that's what happens when you have
genuine hierarchies of competence and so
you to,
you listen to these panderers of
egalitarianism,
a gala,
inequity,
and they failed to recognize completely
that there are differences in rank
between people.
It's not such a terrible thing,
man.
Maybe you wouldn't be a great lawyer
like it's certainly possible.
Most people aren't,
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at.
There's lots of hierarchies to attempt
to climb and if you fail in one,
go try in another.
But the point is you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do if you don't try to aim
for the top,
you know,
flap about uselessly and whine about
your life.
It's not helpful.
It just make you miserable.
You're not reliable to anyone.
You can't help out in a crisis.
It's like,
so you tell young people,
and this is another message for
conservatives,
like,
I don't care why you're going to do,
but go out there and make something of
yourself for God's sake.
Be An honest person and work and get to
the top of whatever it is that you want
to get to the top of you know,
and,
and stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a
blight,
you know,
and you can tell young people that and
they haven't been told that by anyone
now and so the young men are so hungry
for that,
that it's,
it's painful to watch.
They're so relieved when it was.
Someone finally comes up and says,
Hey,
you know,
you get your act together a bit.
Disciplined yourself.
See if you can learn to tell the truth,
concentrate on something for a year or
two.
You could be a bloody world beater.
They think really?
That's possible.
Wow.
That would be,
that would be interesting.
That might make life or life worth
living like,
yeah,
it might.
So why don't you go do it?
That's what the damn universities we're
supposed to be teaching people and
they've forgotten that.
I went to Harvard month ago,
month and a half,
used to teach there and I talked to a
bunch of students.
You know what I told them,
it's not easy to get into Harvard,
you know,
like you're a Valedictorian if you're at
Harvard and not only are you a
Valedictorian,
you're way better than most people at at
least two other things or you don't get
it.
It's so like it's.
I don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent and believe me,
not everybody applies.
So it's a very selective school.
And so why am I saying that?
It's like these are high quality kids.
So I told them what I just told you.
It's like,
here you are at Harvard.
It's like get yourself educated man.
Read some books,
learn to talk,
learn to think.
Make yourself into something.
Get the hell out there and make the
world that put you here.
Happy that you were put there in that
great institution,
you know,
and they came up to me afterwards and
said,
God,
I wish someone would have told us that
when we were in our first year.
It's like,
Jesus,
why didn't someone tell them that for
God's sake,
it's supposed to be the greatest
university in the world.
Is it so difficult to figure that out?
Well,
it is.
If that is what you want to have
happened in the university,
you want to make cringing milk sops to
whine about being victims while they're
going to ivy league institutions.
Jesus.
It's pathetic.